And I would say that the first two answers are probably the ones that
are the most accurate.
So testing data of course gives you an assessment of the performance of your
classifier or your regression on an independent data set and
also helps you prevent overfitting.
The experts do say that you should do this training testing split but
that's not really the reason why we do it.
We do it because it helps us understand our results better.
And one thing that it definitely doesn't do is maximize the amount of
training data available.
So if you have to hold out 10 or 20% of your data for
testing, then of course that's not going to be available when training.
And this is one drawback of the training testing split.